[Música]
repasamos la información económica aquí
en directo a América de Francia 24 Juan
Pablo un saludo nuevamente para usted
acá seguimos nuevamente acá seguimos
vamos a ver los resultados de la
actividad empresarial en la zona Euro Y
si mejoró empeoró o se quedó igual eso
revisaremos Ángela y lo haremos con base
al índice compuesto de gerentes de
compras conocido como El pmi y que es el
considerado como un buen indicador para
medir la salud económica en general el
índice pm Y subió entonces 50,2 este mes
de enero desde el 49,3 de diciembre de
2022 en la zona Euro y estas dos décimas
por encima del 50 entero que
Precisamente es ahí donde se separa el
crecimiento de la contracción de la
actividad de este índice pues podemos
ver que esas dos décimas básicamente han
avanzado han mejorado para la eurozona
para ver un panorama de cómo le fue a la
zona Euro también podemos revisar el
caso de la primera y la segunda economía
europea así como el caso aparte de Reino
Unido la número uno Alemania superó por
7 décimas su cifra de diciembre mientras
que la segunda economía estamos hablando
de Francia perdió una décima de los
449,1 puntos de diciembre de 2022
Mientras tanto Reino Unido que no
Comparte el euro como pues moneda cayó
bastante al 49 que estaba en diciembre
al 47,8 en enero y con esto es uno de
los países que estaría en mayor riesgo
de caer en recesión los mercados
financieros esperan entonces que el
Banco Central británico eleve las tasas
al 4% desde el 3,5% la próxima semana
para hacer frente a la inflación de dos
dígitos que en diciembre alcanzó el
10,5% interanual en otros temas ayer en
la reunión de los presidentes de
Argentina y Brasil se firmaron varios
acuerdos Cuál es el resumen de lo que se
firmó Ángela pues la casa rosada el
Palacio presidencial de Argentina
publicó cuáles fueron estos acuerdos en
materia de salud se firmó un convenio de
Marco de cooperación con enfoque de
Derechos Humanos salud reproductiva e
igualdad de género en ciencia tecnología
Innovación se firmó un acuerdo para
investigación nu transición energética
nanotecnología biotecnología entre otros
este también se firmó ayer en materia de
defensa se firmó uno para el suministro
de insumos y conocimiento mutuo estamos
hablando de vehículos de combate de
inteligencia Y transferencia Pues de
tecnología y para economía que es el que
nos interesa a nosotros fue el enfoque
hacia una integración de la región para
tratar de integrar de manera general
pues lo que es Suramérica en el tema de
economía se dieron detalles sobre esta
propuesta de la moneda común Qué dijeron
Pues precisamente ellos hablaron y
dijeron que todavía no saben cómo será
esta moneda común no saben si primero
trabaje para Argentina y Brasil y
tampoco como será para Suramérica Esto
fue lo que ellos dijeron la verdad que
no sabemos cómo podría funcionar
una moneda común
funcionaría una moneda
una moneda común en la región minsa como
funcionario Pero lo que sí sabemos es
cómo funcionan las economías dependiendo
de monedas extranjeras para poder
comerciar digamos
lo nocivo de todo eso
[Música]
como se intentó hacer con los países
creo que eso va a suceder
y creo que es necesario que suceda
también hay noticias de Venezuela Así es
cientos de personas salieron a las
calles para exigirle al presidente
Nicolás Maduro mejores salarios y
pensiones el grupo era de trabajadores
del sector público maestros enfermeras y
policías retirados Y es que los
trabajadores de los sectores de los si
los trabajadores y los sectores también
de Educación y salud de Venezuela han
realizado tres protestas pacíficas en
ciudades en lo que va del año
simpatizantes del presidente maduro
también salieron a las calles pero para
mostrar el apoyo al mandatario y pedir
que se retiren las sanciones
internacionales sobre Venezuela maduro
además también se refirió al proyecto de
la moneda común diciendo que la apoyan
yo anuncio
que Venezuela está preparada
y apoyamos la iniciativa de crear una
moneda latinoamericana y caribeña
un tema del que se sigue hablando pero
sigue quedando en el aire no hay
Claridad como lo decían los presidentes
de Argentina y de Brasil ellos mismos lo
confirmaron Así es indicadores Juan
Pablo pues está esperando el informe de
ganancias de Microsoft Pero esto se dará
después de la campana después del cierre
de Wall Street vamos a las acciones de
Asia Porque cerraron en terreno positivo
después de un repunte de Wall Street
impulsado por fuertes compras de
acciones tecnológicas mientras los
inversionistas apostaban a que la
reserva Federal reducirá el alza de sus
tasas a medida que avanza la reducción
de la inflación las bolsas europeas
siguen operando en terreno mixto
optimistas por los resultados positivos
de la actividad empresarial que recién
Nosotros acabamos de hablar de la zona
de oro a medida que pues también
empiezan a cambiar las preocupaciones
por algunas economías del bloque Juan
Pablo gracias por este completo resumen
y mañana vendrán más noticias mañana
tendremos mucho más gracias a